This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. There are moments in any journey when things can feel intominable. You show up to work every day, do the same job, meet the same people. At home, you wash the dishes, clean the bedroom, do the laundry. On weekends, you watch the same TV shows, go for the same walks, talk to the same relatives. One day starts to look like the next. Weeks blur into each other. And then you start to wonder, what am I really doing? Where am I headed? Am I making any progress at all? We have different names for this phenomenon. Writers say they are blocked.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedantam。在任何旅程中，总有一些时刻会让人感到无休无止。你每天去上班，做同样的工作，见同样的人。在家里，你洗碗、打扫卧室、洗衣服。周末，你看同样的电视节目，走同样的路线，和同样的亲戚聊天。一天开始变得和下一天没什么两样。几周的时间模糊地交织在一起。然后你开始怀疑，我到底在做什么？我要去向何方？我真的有取得任何进展吗？我们对这种现象有不同的称呼。作家们说他们遇到了瓶颈。
Office workers talk about being in a rut. People of a certain age call it a midlife crisis. But they are all different ways of saying, I'm stuck. Today, we begin our Parenelyie popular annual series, U2.0. In past years, we have explored ideas about how to communicate better or build stronger relationships. In the coming weeks, we will explore a variety of new ideas to help you thrive.
上班族说自己陷入了死胡同。特定年龄段的人称之为中年危机。但这些都是在表达同一种意思：我被困住了。今天，我们开启备受欢迎的年度系列节目“U2.0”。在过去几年里，我们探讨了如何更好地沟通或建立更稳固关系的理念。在接下来的几周里，我们将探索各种新想法，帮助你茁壮成长。
This week on Hidden Brain, new research into the science of feeling stuck and powerful insights into how to get unstuck. All of us have had moments in our lives when we feel stuck. We don't know what we want to do. Or if we do know what we want, we don't know how to do it. At New York University, psychologist Adam Alter studies the science of how to get unstuck. Adam Alter, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much, Shankar.
本周的Hidden Brain，将带来关于“感到被困住”这一心理状态的最新研究，以及如何摆脱困境的深刻见解。我们所有人在生活中都有过感到被困住的时刻。我们不知道自己想做什么。或者即使知道自己想要什么，也不知道该如何实现。在纽约大学，心理学家Adam Alter研究了如何摆脱困境的科学。Adam Alter，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。非常感谢，Shankar。
Adam, I want to play you a clip from a very dramatic and popular TV series. This is from the season 7 we're going to survive. Because the enemy is real. It's always been real. Now Adam, you've spent some time thinking about this because even as the TV show is widely dramatic and packed with action, something very curious was happening to the writer of the series. Tell me how George R.R. Martin started writing this epic fantasy and what happened along the way. Well, he started very successfully.
Adam，我想给你播放一段非常戏剧化且受欢迎的电视剧片段。这是来自第七季的……我们一定会活下去。因为敌人是真实的。它一直都是真实的。现在，Adam，你花了一些时间思考这个问题，因为尽管这部电视剧非常戏剧化且充满动作场面，但该剧的编剧身上却发生了一些非常奇怪的事情。告诉我George R.R. Martin是如何开始创作这部史诗奇幻作品的，以及在此过程中发生了什么。嗯，他开始得非常成功。
He wrote a number of books in the series and the gap between those books grew larger and larger to the point where he experienced what he described as profound writers block. And he's expressed great puzzlement because he was so productive for so long, but now says in interviews, I don't really have an explanation for you. I know you as the fans of the series are looking for the next installment. It's been many years. I just don't know what to say. I just haven't been able to produce it. And that's
他写了该系列中的几本书，但这些书之间的间隔越来越长，以至于他经历了所谓的严重的写作障碍。他表达了极大的困惑，因为他长期以来一直非常高产，但现在在采访中说，我真的无法向你解释。我知道你们作为该系列的粉丝都在期待下一部作品。已经过去很多年了。我只是不知道该说什么。我就是没能写出来。而这就是
where we sit now. So fans of the books are waiting for the next installment to be released, even as the TV show itself has been completed. In an interview in 2018, he said, I know there are a lot of people out there who are very angry with me that wins of winter. This is the sixth volume out of seven, isn't finished. And I'm mad about that myself. I wish I finished it four years ago. I wish it was finished now, but it's not. But I've had dark nights of the soul where I've pounded my head against the keyboard and said, God, will I ever finish this? The show is going further and further forward. He's talking here about Game of Thrones, and I'm falling further and further behind what the
我们现在的处境。所以书迷们正在等待下一部作品的发布，尽管电视剧本身已经完结。在2018年的一次采访中，他说，我知道外面有很多人对我非常生气，因为《凛冬的寒风》——这是七卷中的第六卷——还没有完成。我自己也为此感到愤怒。我希望我四年前就完成了它。我希望它现在已经完成了，但事实并非如此。但我经历过灵魂的至暗时刻，我曾对着键盘捶打自己的头，说，上帝啊，我还能完成它吗？剧集在不断向前推进，他这里指的是《权力的游戏》，而我却落后得越来越远，这到底
hell is happening here. And you can almost hear his own mystification about his own block here at him. He's very distressed. Yeah, it's interesting when you see someone who is such a colossal talent for writing these kinds of stories. And yet still, we're not talking about being stuck for a day or a week or a month.
是怎么回事？在这里，你几乎可以听到他对自己这种瓶颈状态的困惑。他非常痛苦。是的，当你看到一个在创作这类故事方面拥有如此巨大天赋的人时，这很有趣。然而，我们谈论的并不是被困住一天、一周或一个月。
We're talking about a matter of many years. And he has no idea what he's supposed to be doing moving forward. So it's a very profound case of stuckness. So you say that George R.R. Martin and people like him might have something to learn from an experiment conducted many years ago by the psychologist Clark Hall. What makes this experiment unusual is that the test subjects, one mice? Yeah, that's right. Hall was a behaviorist, and a lot of behaviorists
我们谈论的是长达数年的时间。他根本不知道自己接下来该做什么。所以这是一个非常严重的“被困”案例。所以你说George R.R. Martin和像他这样的人，或许可以从心理学家Clark Hull多年前进行的一项实验中学到一些东西。是什么让这个实验与众不同呢？实验对象是老鼠？是的，没错。Hull是一位行为主义者，那个时期，也就是20世纪中期，很多行为主义者
in that period in the middle of the 20th century studied mice because they were very easy to study. They were very interested in some very basic psychological principles that applied to mice just as they did to humans. And so Hull used to create mazes for his mice and he would watch as they completed these mazes. What do mice running through a maze have to do with the rider of epic fantasy novels, getting stuck? The thing that he noticed most was that the mice when they first entered the maze were quite slow to move. They were puzzled by the situation that faced them.
研究老鼠，因为它们非常容易研究。他们对一些适用于老鼠也同样适用于人类的基本心理学原理非常感兴趣。因此，Hull过去常为他的老鼠制作迷宫，并观察它们完成这些迷宫的过程。在迷宫中奔跑的老鼠与创作史诗奇幻小说的作家被困住有什么关系？他注意到最重要的一点是，老鼠在刚进入迷宫时移动得相当缓慢。它们对所面临的情况感到困惑。
But as the goal, whatever the goal was, whether it was a piece of food or whether it was exiting the maze, as the goal came into view, they moved much more quickly. And he described this as the goal gradient. It's the idea that, at least subjectively, it feels to mice and actually to humans as well as though, as you can see the goal in sight, that the experience becomes almost metaphorically downhill. It's much easier to bridge the gap between where you are and where you'd like to be. I think all of us have had this experience in one form or the other. You feel like the end is inside, whether you're a runner and you can see the finish tape inside. It does give you a bit of
但随着目标——无论目标是什么，是一块食物还是走出迷宫——进入视野，它们移动得快多了。他将其描述为“目标梯度”。这个想法是，至少在主观上，对于老鼠，实际上对于人类来说，当你能看到目标在望时，这种体验在隐喻上变得几乎是下坡路。弥合你所在位置和你想要到达位置之间的差距要容易得多。我想我们所有人都以这样或那样的形式经历过这种体验。你觉得终点就在眼前，无论你是一名跑步者，还是能看到终点线。这确实给了你一点
a spurt to get to the finish line. But talk a minute about this goal gradient idea because there's something really interesting that happens here at the start, the middle, and at the end. What happens at it? Yes, so the original idea that Holda's cried was that we're much quicker closer to the goal, but subsequent research has shown that it's a bit more complicated than that, that actually we slow down dramatically in the middle when we're sort of unmoored, where somewhere between the beginning of the goal and the end of the goal. And so we move quickly at the beginning because we have a bit of motivation,
冲刺到终点线的动力。但请谈谈这个“目标梯度”的概念，因为在开始、中间和结束时，这里发生了一些非常有趣的事情。发生了什么？是的，Hull描述的最初想法是，我们离目标越近，速度就越快，但随后的研究表明，情况要复杂一些，实际上我们在中间阶段会明显减速，当我们处于一种“无锚”状态时，也就是在目标开始和结束之间的某个地方。所以我们在开始时移动得很快，因为我们有一点动力，
we're fresh, we're ready to go, and we slow down in the middle. And then as we get to the end of the process, we speed up again as the goal comes within view. So it's a sort of u-shape. You go quickly, then slowly, then quickly again. Adam says it is revealing that George R.R. Martin got stuck as he was slogging his way through the series. The end of the series was some distance away, while the start of the project was in the distant past. There's lots of evidence that the goal gradient effect plays a powerful role in many dimensions of our lives. There are some studies that show that it applies
我们精力充沛，准备出发，然后在中间阶段减速。然后当我们接近过程的尾声时，随着目标进入视野，我们再次加速。所以这是一种U型曲线。你走得快，然后慢，然后又快起来。Adam说，George R.R. Martin在艰难推进系列作品时被困住，这很有启发性。系列作品的终点还很遥远，而项目的起点已在遥远的过去。有大量证据表明，目标梯度效应在我们生活的许多维度中都发挥着强大的作用。有一些研究表明它适用于
to physical activity, but it applies just as much to mental activity as well. So there were some studies that were run asking people, for example, one of my colleagues, Andrea Bonetti, and his colleagues asked people to find words within words. So he would give them a long word, and then he would say how many shorter English words
身体活动，但也同样适用于心理活动。所以有一些研究是这样进行的，要求人们，例如，我的同事Andrea Bonetti和他的同事要求人们在单词中寻找单词。所以他会给他们一个长单词，然后说有多少个较短的英语单词
can you find within the letters of this longer word. And he did that nine times. And what he found was that people were slowest around the fifth attempt, much slower than around the first or second or eighth or ninth attempts. And so this applies just as much in his studies to mental activities where there's some motivation required as it does to physical activities. activities where there's some motivation required as it does to physical activities. I understand this is also true when it comes to paying off credit card debt. You know, you can, you make a good start at the beginning and if you get close to the end, you can, you feel like you have a sport to finish off, but the middle is really difficult again. That's right. Yeah, there's quite a lot of research on the financial implications of this,
你能在这些长单词的字母中找到。他做了九次。他发现人们在第五次尝试时最慢，比第一次、第二次、第八次或第九次尝试时慢得多。因此，这在他的研究中同样适用于需要一定动力的心理活动，就像它适用于身体活动一样。我明白，当涉及到偿还信用卡债务时，这也是事实。你知道，你可以在开始时有一个良好的开端，如果你接近尾声，你可以，你觉得你有冲刺去完成它，但中间部分又变得非常困难。没错。是的，关于这一点的财务影响有很多研究，
this stuck in the middle effect as it's known that shows exactly that, that we pay off credit card debt quickly, then slowly, then quickly. When we're donating to charities, you see something similar. We donate much more readily and we donate larger amounts at the beginning when the charity first makes the solicitation. Then again, as the charity reaches its goal or approaches its goal, we donate again. But in the middle process, say the charity is looking for $100,000, around that $50,000 mark,
这种被称为“中间被困”的效应，准确地显示了这一点，即我们偿还信用卡债务时是先快，然后慢，最后又快。当我们向慈善机构捐款时，你也会看到类似的情况。我们在慈善机构最初发出募捐时，捐款更积极，金额也更大。然后，当慈善机构达到其目标或接近其目标时，我们再次捐款。但在中间过程中，假设慈善机构正在寻求10万美元，在5万美元左右的关口，
you see a slowdown collectively and how much people give. So, you argue that one of the reasons that the middle of a project is so challenging is that there are fewer and fewer landmarks to mark our progress. And you've compared the journey we take on a long project to the experience of a sailor on a ship traveling across the Atlantic Ocean from the United States to Britain. Explain that analogy, Adam. Yeah, so when you leave, imagine you're sailing from New York to say Southampton in Britain. When you leave, you have a number of landmarks behind you and that, you know, there's a lot of activity at the beginning of that journey. Things that suggest that you're
你会看到人们捐款的集体放缓。所以，你认为项目中间阶段如此具有挑战性的原因之一是，标记我们进展的里程碑越来越少。你把我们在长期项目中所经历的旅程比作一名水手在船上横跨大西洋从美国前往英国的经历。解释一下这个类比，Adam。是的，所以当你离开时，想象你正从纽约航行到英国的南安普敦。当你离开时，你身后有许多里程碑，而且，你知道，在旅程的开始有很多活动。那些表明你正在
moving, you can see how fast you're moving. And when you get into the middle part of that journey, all you see is ocean. But you don't have any external cues that tell you how fast you're moving. And so that middle period is a long period between leaving the land behind and then waiting for the next bit of land to come into view. And so during that period, in contrast to the beginning of the experience, you don't have a lot of feedback about your progress and that's demotivating. It gives you the sense that you're not really making progress even if you're moving quite rapidly.
移动的事物，你可以看到你移动得有多快。当你进入那段旅程的中间部分时，你看到的只有海洋。但你没有任何外部线索告诉你移动得有多快。因此，那段中间时期是离开陆地后到等待下一块陆地进入视野之间的漫长时期。因此，在那段时期，与体验的开始相比，你没有关于进展的反馈，这会让人失去动力。它让你觉得你并没有真正取得进展，即使你移动得相当快。
And then of course, as you approach Britain again, you see land, you might see parts of the British Isles and again you can start to see how fast you see land, you might see parts of the British Isles, and again you can start to see how fast you're moving, you're getting some external cues that are reinforcing. They say, keep going, you're almost there. And I think that's how a lot of our goals function. We have that middle period that can often be quite expansive, where we just have no sense that we're making progress, and so that's greatly demotivating.
然后当然，当你再次接近英国时，你看到了陆地，你可能会看到不列颠群岛的部分地区，再次，你可以开始看到你移动得有多快，你得到了一些强化的外部线索。它们说，继续前进，你快到了。我认为这就是我们许多目标运作的方式。我们有那段往往相当漫长的中间时期，在那里我们根本感觉不到自己在取得进展，所以这非常令人沮丧。
So is one solution then to try and create more landmarks in the middle? I think so. I think it's to shrink the middle as far as possible, and there are different ways to do that. In the case of sailing, there aren't that many options, but what you want to do is to give yourself some sort of feedback that suggests that you're making progress, and so you might create sub-goles. Instead of thinking of the journey as a single goal from start to finish, you might say, well, I've got this map that I'm using to navigate through the Atlantic Ocean. I know when I hit certain latitude or longitudinal measures,
那么，一个解决方案是尝试在中间创造更多的里程碑吗？我想是的。我认为是要尽可能缩短中间部分，有不同的方法可以做到这一点。在航海的情况下，选择并不多，但你想做的是给自己某种反馈，表明你正在取得进展，所以你可能会创造子目标。与其把旅程看作从开始到结束的单一目标，你可能会说，好吧，我有这张地图，我用它来导航穿越大西洋。我知道当我达到一定的纬度或经度测量值时，
I know that I've reached a certain percentage of the way. And that's obviously much easier to do when you're engaged in some sort of activity, whether it's running or whether it's some sort of mental activity. You just kind of shrink the goal down and you bracket it much more narrowly, so you have these smaller sub-galls. So runners often say, you know, my goal is to run the next mile or the next half-mile, or even, you know, as far as my eye can see, and you set a target, and you run to that
我知道我已经达到了某种百分比的进度。当你从事某种活动时，无论是跑步还是某种心理活动，这显然要容易得多。你只是把目标缩小，把它框定得更窄，这样你就有了这些更小的子目标。所以跑步者经常说，你知道，我的目标是跑下一英里或下一半英里，甚至，你知道，只要我的眼睛能看到的地方，你设定一个目标，然后你跑到那个
target, and then you look at another target, and you run to that target. And it's the same principle again. You're trying to be ending the race all the time. Exactly. Yeah. You're sort of atomizing the goal. You're turning it into its bait most basic elements. And at the very extreme point, if you have ever run and feel that you're really struggling, it becomes a matter of taking one step at a time. You know, each step is its own little goal and you get your own little burst of positive feedback with each step. I understand that you have employed a similar insight when it comes to writing. What does that look like, Adam?
目标，然后你看着另一个目标，然后你跑到那个目标。这又是同样的原则。你一直在试图结束比赛。完全正确。是的。你是在把目标原子化。你把它变成了最基本的元素。在最极端的情况下，如果你曾经跑过步并觉得真的很挣扎，那就变成了一次迈出一步的问题。你知道，每一步都是它自己的小目标，每一步你都会得到一点点积极的反馈。我明白你在写作方面也采用了类似的见解。那是什么样子的，Adam？
Yeah, so, you know, writing is very similar. If you're writing something large, like a thesis or a book or an article, there are different ways to construe that goal. Now, obviously, if you zoom back far enough, the goal is to finish the book or finish the article. But that's overwhelming, in the same way that sailing a ship across the ocean might be overwhelming. And so you might have this stuck in the middle experience, which I think a lot of people do. The nice thing about writing a book is it's broken naturally into chapters. So already, you shrunk those middles down, let's say there are 12 chapters in a book that you're writing. You've taken that large goal and you've made
是的，所以，你知道，写作非常相似。如果你正在写一些大型的东西，比如论文、书或文章，有不同的方式来解释那个目标。现在，显然，如果你退后得足够远，目标就是完成书或完成文章。但这让人不知所措，就像横跨大西洋航行可能让人不知所措一样。所以你可能会有这种“中间被困”的体验，我认为很多人都有。写书的好处是它自然地分成了章节。所以你已经缩短了那些中间部分，假设你正在写的书有12章。你已经把那个大目标拿走了，并且通过拥有这些落在那个大伞下的12个子目标，确保了
sure that the middle is smaller by having these 12 sub-goles that fall under that larger umbrella. But even within a chapter, you know, people will say, every hundred words is my goal. And I've often used that tactic, especially as the process of writing becomes difficult or when you're entering a difficult part of a story or a study that you're trying to describe, what I find is that the goal for me shrinks as I am struggling more, as I become more stuck, and it grows again as the process of writing
中间部分更小。但即使在章节内，你知道，人们会说，每一百个字是我的目标。我经常使用这种策略，特别是当写作过程变得困难时，或者当你进入故事或你试图描述的研究的困难部分时，我发现当我挣扎得更多，当我变得更被困时，我的目标就会缩小，而当写作过程
feels a bit easier. And I find that shrinking and expanding happens constantly as I'm writing the book. I understand that you sometimes set the timer on your watch for 60 seconds and aim to write until the timer goes off. Why would you set a timer to write for only one minute? Yeah, these are the most desperate moments, right? You don't want to write for a minute and think about that as the height of what you're
感觉稍微容易一点时，它又会增长。我发现当我写书时，这种缩小和扩大不断发生。我明白你有时会在手表上设置60秒的计时器，并目标是写到计时器响起。为什么要设置计时器只写一分钟？是的，这些是最绝望的时刻，对吧？你不想写一分钟并认为这是你
trying to achieve. You obviously want to do much more than that. But there are moments when writing is incredibly difficult in the same way that George R.R. Martin describes it, where any writing is a small victory. And so what you can do is just as a runner might say, every step is a little victory. You might say that writing for 60 seconds,
试图实现的最高点。你显然想做更多。但有些时刻写作非常困难，就像George R.R. Martin描述的那样，任何写作都是一场小小的胜利。所以你可以做的是，就像跑步者可能会说，每一步都是一场小胜利。你可能会说，写60秒，
or even 15 or 30 seconds if you're very desperate, is its own goal. And the idea behind that is trying to lubricate whatever machinery is required to ride for 10 minutes and then an hour and then three and five and so on. And I find that works pretty well because there's a lot of inertia in a lot of these processes that are goal based, where once you get the ball rolling, things seem to improve, but getting the ball rolling can be really difficult. And the best way to do that is to lower the bar as far as possible,
或者如果你非常绝望，甚至15或30秒，都是它自己的目标。这背后的想法是试图润滑写作10分钟，然后一小时，然后三小时、五小时等等所需的任何机器。我发现这很有效，因为在许多基于目标的流程中有很多惯性，一旦你让球滚动起来，事情似乎就会改善，但让球滚动起来可能真的很难。最好的方法是尽可能降低门槛，
so it's barely above the ground. And I think many people notice this, you know, when there's a deadline looming, suddenly people start working much faster, and then right as they approach the deadline, they sort of say, you know, I have all these ideas bursting at my head right now, if I could only have another half an hour, you know, I could get a lot of it down. And so what you're basically saying is take advantage of that and create
让它几乎就在地面上方。我认为很多人注意到了这一点，你知道，当截止日期临近时，人们突然开始工作得快得多，然后就在他们接近截止日期时，他们会说，你知道，我现在脑子里涌现出所有这些想法，如果我能再有半小时，你知道，我就能写下很多。所以你基本上是在说，利用这一点并创造
artificial deadlines in order to get yourself jump started. Yeah, that's exactly right. And I think by constraining yourself, either by a deadline or by saying, I'm only going to write for a minute, something about that process of constraining yourself is paradoxically liberating. A lot of the extraneous material that might have by saying I'm only going to write for a minute, something about that process of constraining yourself is paradoxically liberating. A lot of the extraneous material that might have been weighing on our minds and sapping limited mental resources goes by the wayside.
人为的截止日期，以便让自己启动。是的，完全正确。而且我认为通过限制自己，无论是通过截止日期还是通过说，我只写一分钟，关于限制自己的某种过程在悖论上是解放的。很多可能已经……通过说我只写一分钟，关于限制自己的某种过程在悖论上是解放的。很多可能已经压在我们心头并消耗有限心理资源的无关材料被抛弃了。
What's left is just this real sense of sudden clarity, which I've always found really inspires great ideas and inspires a lot of activity, especially when I feel stuck. The middle of any extended project can be a trap. Becoming aware of this fact can help us prepare for the trap and to make plans to unstick ourselves. But of course, the middle of projects is not the only reason people get stuck. There are lots of other drivers and it turns out we create many of the problems ourselves. When we come back, how we get in our own way and how to get out. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
剩下的只是这种突然清晰的真实感，我一直发现这真的激发了伟大的想法并激发了大量的活动，特别是在我感到被困住的时候。任何扩展项目的中间部分都可能是一个陷阱。意识到这一事实可以帮助我们为陷阱做好准备，并制定计划来摆脱困境。但当然，项目的中间部分并不是人们被困住的唯一原因。还有很多其他的驱动因素，事实证明我们自己制造了许多问题。当我们回来时，我们将探讨我们如何阻碍自己以及如何摆脱困境。你正在收听Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedantam。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Adam Alter is a psychologist at New York University. He has studied why we get stuck and how we can get ourselves unstuck. One thing he and others have found is that many of the obstacles that stand between us and our goals are created by us. Adam, in your book, anatomy of a breakthrough, you illustrate one of these obstacles with a story about a musician. I want to play you a clip of a song. How I look close we get sometimes It's like we never met But you and I I think we can take it
这里是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedantam。Adam Alter是纽约大学的心理学家。他研究了我们为什么会被困住以及我们如何才能摆脱困境。他和其他人发现的一件事是，许多阻碍我们实现目标的障碍都是我们自己制造的。Adam，在你的书《突破的解剖》中，你用一个关于音乐家的故事说明了其中一个障碍。我想给你播放一段歌曲片段。我们有时靠得有多近，就像我们从未见过面，但你和我，我想我们可以接受它。
Adam tell me Jeff Tweety's story and the trap he once constructed for himself. So Tweety is the front man of the band Wilco and he is a bit of a renaissance man. He writes music, but he also writes books. And he has described quite vividly his own experiences with writers' block in both contexts and talked quite a lot about how he's managed to unstick himself over time. One problem that Jeff Tweety has battled will be familiar to many people. Perfectionism. Perfectionism is paralyzing because what it basically does is it signals to you that unless you're producing perfection, you're failing. And so the feedback that you're getting constantly,
Adam，告诉我Jeff Tweety的故事以及他曾经为自己设置的陷阱。所以Tweety是Wilco乐队的主唱，他是一个有点文艺复兴式的人。他创作音乐，但也写书。他非常生动地描述了他在两种背景下对写作障碍的亲身经历，并谈了很多关于他如何随着时间的推移设法摆脱困境。Jeff Tweety所抗争的一个问题对许多人来说都很熟悉。完美主义。完美主义是令人瘫痪的，因为它基本上向你发出信号，除非你产生完美，否则你就是失败的。所以你不断得到的反馈，
since most of us aren't perfect most of the time, is negative feedback. And it's demotivating. And it also means that when you ask yourself at the end of a period, whether it's a few hours or at the end of a day, whether you've produced anything, because perfectionism is essentially binary, the feedback you get is that you have failed most days or many days. And so people like Tweety who have created this trap for themselves find that it's very, very hard to be motivated across time. And so the products they create, few and far between,
因为我们大多数人大部分时间都不完美，是负面反馈。这令人沮丧。这也意味着当你问自己在一段时间结束时，无论是几个小时还是一天结束时，你是否产生了任何东西，因为完美主义本质上是二元的，你得到的反馈是你大多数日子或许多日子都失败了。所以像Tweety这样为自己制造了这个陷阱的人发现，随着时间的推移保持动力非常非常困难。所以他们创造的产品，寥寥无几，
and then they often feel quite negative about what they've created. So you see that Jeff Tweed has come up with an ingenious way of battling this challenge. What does he do? Yeah, he has this great description. This term, he says he pours out the bad material. So the way he thinks about it,
然后他们往往对自己创造的东西感觉非常消极。所以你看到Jeff Tweed想出了一种巧妙的方法来对抗这个挑战。他做了什么？是的，他有这个很棒的描述。这个词，他说他倒出了坏材料。所以他思考它的方式，
and I think this is true of a lot of creative enterprises, is the obvious stuff, is stuff that's, you know, not particularly novel or interesting, and that's the stuff that sits at the top of your head. And what you've got to do is, if you imagine that all your ideas are essentially liquids sitting one on top of the other, you've got to pour out the bad stuff, and that's what Tweety describes. He wakes up in the morning and he says, I've got to pour out the bad material. And what's incredibly liberating about that in contrast to perfectionism is this idea that you expect that to be mediocre.
我认为这适用于许多创造性企业，是显而易见的东西，是，你知道，不是特别新颖或有趣的东西，而那是坐在你头顶上的东西。你必须做的是，如果你想象你所有的想法本质上是液体一个接一个地坐在另一个上面，你必须倒出坏东西，而这就是Tweety描述的。他早上醒来，他说，我必须倒出坏材料。与完美主义相比，这在某种程度上令人难以置信地解放，这是你期望它是平庸的想法。
And that's okay because the way you think about it is you're getting the bad stuff out of the way so the good stuff can emerge. And so I understand he deliberately sometimes tries to pour out bad stuff, he tries to come up with bad stuff. So the good stuff can then emerge? Yeah, the nice thing about removing all requirements for quality is that quantity rises. And so if being unstuck is about moving forward, the idea that you don't care about quality,
这没关系，因为你思考它的方式是你正在把坏东西清理掉，这样好东西才能浮现。所以我明白他有时会故意尝试倒出坏东西，他尝试想出坏东西。所以好东西然后才能浮现？是的，消除所有质量要求的好处是数量上升。所以如果摆脱困境是关于前进，那么你不关心质量的想法，
but you care only about something coming out, anything coming out, means that you get into this really great habit of actually making some progress later on and And by even trying to write bad songs He finds that that shows him what's good because by making something bad if you're as successful and as talented as he is It shows you something about where you're not looking for and then later on you use that as a as a sort of contrast point and you produce better material You argue that perfectionism is an aspect of a larger tendency we have, which is to understand goal-presued in moral terms. What do you mean by this atom? Yeah, I think people who succeed seem in some moral sense to be better than those who
但你只关心有什么东西出来，任何东西出来，意味着你养成了一个非常好的习惯，即在以后真正取得一些进展，而且通过甚至尝试写坏歌，他发现这向他展示了什么是好的，因为通过制造一些坏的东西，如果你像他一样成功和有才华，它会向你展示一些关于你不是在寻找什么的地方，然后以后你把它用作一种对比点，你产生更好的材料。你认为完美主义是我们拥有的更大倾向的一个方面，即以道德术语理解目标追求。你这是什么意思，Adam？是的，我认为那些成功的人在某种道德意义上似乎比那些
fail. And I think that's tied to the idea that, you know, from hard work comes success. And so if you're constantly failing, perhaps you're not working hard enough, perhaps you're not capitalizing on whatever talents you might have and so on. And so there's a strong moral dimension to not succeeding. I mean, it's also the case that I think many of us equate goals with self-respect. So if we don't reach a goal, we feel like we've lost respect for ourselves. Yeah, that's right. I think humans as a species are completionists. It's very important to us to finish things even if the exercise is futile.
失败的人更好。我认为这与以下想法有关，你知道，从努力工作中获得成功。所以如果你不断失败，也许你没有足够努力，也许你没有利用你可能拥有的任何天赋等等。所以不成功有一个强烈的道德维度。我的意思是，这也是事实，我认为我们许多人将目标等同于自尊。所以如果我们没有达到目标，我们觉得我们失去了对自己的尊重。是的，没错。我认为人类作为一个物种是完成主义者。完成事情对我们来说非常重要，即使练习是徒劳的。
And so this idea of finishing something you start has a strong moral element to it. When we turn ordinary goals into moral causes, we switch from being what social scientists call satisfiesers to maximizers. Instead of asking if what we have accomplished is good enough, we adopt all or nothing thinking. If you decide you want to run a marathon in under three hours and finish the race in three hours and ten minutes, this extraordinary feat of human endurance gets counted as a failure. If you want to write five articles in the course of a year, but only manage four, this means you fall in short. If you decide you want to save a thousand dollars more in a savings account,
所以这种完成你开始的事情的想法对它有很强的道德元素。当我们把普通目标变成道德事业时，我们从社会科学家所说的“满足者”转变为“最大化者”。与其问我们所完成的是否足够好，我们采取全有或全无的思维。如果你决定你想在三小时内跑完马拉松，并在三小时十分钟内完成比赛，这种非凡的人类耐力壮举被算作失败。如果你想在一年内写五篇文章，但只设法写了四篇，这意味着你做得不够。如果你决定你想在储蓄账户中多存一千美元，
putting away $880 can leave you feeling disappointed. Thinking this way can contribute to a feeling of being stuck or what Adam calls stuckness. Yeah, those round numbers are really dangerous in all those contexts because they form artificial goals that we, I say, fetishize and I think that's an accurate description because it's something that we take so seriously that really becomes a legitimate goal for us. One of the other things that you and other researchers have found is that many of us have a tendency to focus on our own struggles while imagining that others have it easy. Talk about how this causes us to become stuck at them.
存入880美元会让你感到失望。以这种方式思考会导致一种被困住的感觉，或者Adam所说的“被困感”。是的，那些整数在所有这些背景下真的很危险，因为它们形成了人为的目标，我们，我说，恋物化，我认为这是一个准确的描述，因为它是我们非常认真对待的东西，真正成为我们合法的目标。你和其他研究人员发现的另一件事是，我们许多人倾向于关注自己的挣扎，同时想象别人很容易。谈谈这如何导致我们被困住，Adam。
Yeah, I did some research and basically found that everyone essentially, in at least one respected stuck, but they also say that it feels very lonely and they imagine that they're the only ones in that position, which is a really interesting finding that even though we're all standing next to each other with these partitions, we don't know what other people are thinking, stuckness is often hidden from view. And so we sort of imagine that it's just us facing
是的，我做了一些研究，基本上发现每个人本质上，在至少一个受人尊敬的方面被困住，但他们也说这感觉非常孤独，他们想象他们是唯一处于那个位置的人，这是一个非常有趣的发明，即使我们都站在彼此旁边，有这些隔板，我们不知道别人在想什么，被困感往往隐藏在视野之外。所以我们有点想象只有我们面临
those particular headwinds, whereas if you had the conversation with other people, you realize that we're all going through something. And that's a really liberating experience when you actually do open up that conversation channel. But even worse than not having conversations about the ways in which we're all stuck, we do have conversations about each other's successes. I mean on social media, you hear about people getting jobs or getting gigs or winning awards or good things happening to them. And of course, even if those good things actually are happening on a relatively rare basis, that's mostly what we hear. And the success stories end up
那些特定的逆风，而如果你与其他人进行对话，你意识到我们都在经历一些事情。当你真正打开那个对话渠道时，这是一种非常解放的体验。但比不进行关于我们都被困住的方式的对话更糟糕的是，我们确实进行了关于彼此成功的对话。我的意思是，在社交媒体上，你听说人们得到工作或得到演出或赢得奖项或好事情发生在他们身上。当然，即使这些好事情实际上是在相对罕见的基础上发生的，那也是我们听到的大部分内容。而成功故事最终
clouding our impression of what's happening in our lives versus the lives of other people. What people are doing on social media is they are sharing the very best 1% of their lives and keeping the other 99% the part that's complicated or messy or that involves stuckness or whatever they term failure from social media for obvious reasons. And so what you end up experiencing, if you're spending one or two or three or four hours a day on these platforms, is you're experiencing everyone else's successes. And that throws into stark relief how different your life is, where the other 99% is real and present and concrete for you. And that doesn't involve success all the time.
掩盖了我们对我们生活中正在发生的事情与其他人生活中的事情的印象。人们在社交媒体上做的是，他们正在分享他们生活中最好的1%，并保留其他99%——复杂或混乱或涉及被困感或无论他们称为什么失败的部分——出于显而易见的原因远离社交媒体。所以你最终体验到的是，如果你每天在这些平台上花费一到两个或三个或四个小时，你正在体验其他所有人的成功。这与你的生活有多么不同形成了鲜明的对比，其中其他99%对你来说是真实的、现在的和具体的。而且这并不总是涉及成功。
Psychologists have a name for this phenomenon, where we all walk around thinking the same thing, but believe we are the only ones having those thoughts. They call it pluralistic ignorance. Yeah, it's a psychological phenomenon where your experience of the world feels very lonely because your understanding of the way other people experience the world is quite different. It usually happens when the thing we're talking about is hidden from view. It only exists in your head. So the classic research on this topic looked at drinking on college campuses.
心理学家对这种现象有一个名字，我们都走来走去想同样的事情，但相信我们是唯一有这些想法的人。他们称之为“多元无知”。是的，这是一种心理现象，你对世界的体验感觉非常孤独，因为你对其他人体验世界的方式的理解是非常不同的。它通常发生在我们谈论的事情隐藏在视野之外时。它只存在于你的脑海中。所以关于这个主题的经典研究观察了大学校园里的饮酒。
And what the researchers found was that when people as individuals report how they feel about drinking on campus, these are college students, they basically say, I think in general, we probably all drink a little bit more than we should on campus. Some say we drink much more than we should. But I think everyone else thinks that the drinking is fine.
研究人员发现，当人们作为个人报告他们对校园饮酒的感觉时，这些是大学生，他们基本上说，我认为总的来说，我们可能都比我们在校园里应该喝的稍微多一点。有些人说我们喝得比我们应该喝的多得多。但我认为其他所有人都认为饮酒没问题。
And so that's just the norm. And I deviate from the norm by thinking we're drinking too much. But actually, when you ask each individual person, the same thing comes up time and time again. Everyone says the same thing. I think we're drinking a little bit too much, but I think everyone else thinks it's fine. The reason they think it's fine is because all you see
所以这只是常态。而我通过认为我们喝得太多而偏离了常态。但实际上，当你问每一个个人时，同样的事情一次又一次地出现。每个人都说同样的话。我认为我们喝得稍微多了一点，但我认为其他所有人都认为这没问题。他们认为这没问题的原因是因为你所看到的
is the behavior of other people, which is that they're all drinking a huge amount. And the same thing happens with stuckness that all you see is people making their ways through the world. But what you experience from your own perspective is something quite different, which is that there are a lot of sticking points
只是其他人的行为，那就是他们都喝了大量的酒。同样的事情也发生在被困感上，你所看到的只是人们在世界上穿行。但你从你自己的角度体验到的是完全不同的东西，那就是有很多卡点
along the way. And they are very, very prominent and very concrete for you and very visible and salient, but they are hidden when they apply to other people. And so you get that same sense of pluralistic ignorance. And in some ways, this speaks to the solution then for this pluralistic ignorance, which is when you feel like you are alone in being stuck,
沿途。而且它们对你来说非常、非常突出且非常具体，非常明显且显著，但当它们应用于其他人时，它们被隐藏了。所以你得到了同样的多元无知感。在某种程度上，这说明了这种多元无知的解决方案，那就是当你觉得你一个人被困住时，
it's really important to actually resist the impulse to withdraw into yourself and actually try and reach out to others. Yeah, I think in any case, a pluralistic ignorance arises only because there's a gap between what you experience and what you perceive in other people. And the only way to break down that gap is to ask whether people in their own heads are experiencing what you're experiencing. And very, very often the answer will be yes.
真正抵制退缩到自己内心的冲动并真正尝试接触其他人真的很重要。是的，我认为在任何情况下，多元无知产生只是因为你体验到的和你感知到其他人身上的东西之间存在差距。打破那个差距的唯一方法是问人们在他们自己的脑海中是否正在体验你正在体验的东西。而且非常、非常经常答案会是肯定的。
There is another way we get in our own way. It's when we assume that progress towards our goals involves following a straight line. Either you're proceeding down the path and making headway or you're off track. But in reality, a long journey is rarely a linear path. This self-inflicted wound turns out to be a problem especially in countries like the United States.
我们阻碍自己的另一种方式。这是当我们假设朝着我们的目标前进涉及遵循直线时。你要么沿着路径前进并取得进展，要么偏离轨道。但实际上，漫长的旅程很少是线性路径。这种自残的伤口在像美国这样的国家尤其是一个问题。
Yeah, this actually goes back to some of the early research I did as a graduate student. I was very interested in how different cultures perceive change. And what I discovered is that in the West, countries like the United States, we tend to experience change as rare. We don't think it happens all that often. And we tend to think of things as linear. And so in some studies, I gave people some stock charts and asked them to predict how
是的，这实际上回到了我作为研究生时所做的一些早期研究。我对不同文化如何感知变化非常感兴趣。我发现的是，在西方，像美国这样的国家，我们倾向于将变化体验为罕见的。我们不认为它经常发生。而且我们倾向于认为事物是线性的。所以，在一些研究中，我给了人们一些股票图表，并要求他们预测
the stock was going to perform. Some of those stocks had done well in the past and they tended to think they'd continue to do well. Some had done poorly. They expected them to continue to do poorly. Or I'd give them some weather charts and I'd say, hey, it's been sunny 10 days in a row. What are you think's going to happen tomorrow? They would predict more sun, or if it had been raining, they predicted more rain. But in the east, in Korea, in Japan, in China, you get the very opposite. And so there's this interesting cultural difference where people in the east seem to predict much more change, variation, balance, correction.
股票将如何表现。其中一些股票在过去表现良好，他们倾向于认为它们会继续表现良好。一些表现不佳。他们预计它们会继续表现不佳。或者我会给他们一些天气图表，我会说，嘿，连续10天阳光明媚。你认为明天会发生什么？他们会预测更多的阳光，或者如果一直在下雨，他们预测更多的雨。但在东方，在韩国，在日本，在中国，你得到的是完全相反的。所以存在这种有趣的文化差异，东方的人似乎预测更多的变化、变异、平衡、修正。
When a stock's been doing well, the other shoe is about to drop, and so the stock's probably gonna decline when it's been doing badly, it's likely to do well, it's been sunny, it's going to start raining and so on. And one of the interesting things about the view that the West seems to have of change, which is that it's unusual, is that it leaves you uniquely ill-prepared for the fact that life is not linear, that actually there are a lot of changes that happen constantly, and
当股票表现良好时，另一只鞋即将掉落，所以股票可能会下跌，当它表现糟糕时，它很可能会表现良好，阳光明媚，它将开始下雨等等。西方似乎对变化持有的观点——即它是不同寻常的——的一个有趣之处在于，它让你对生活不是线性的这一事实准备不足，实际上有很多变化不断发生，而且
we seem to be blindsided by that when we anticipate that there aren't going to be any changes. But from the point of view of being stuck, you can now see a situation where in fact you're going through a period of an extended slump for example and it's easy to feel, you know, I'm never going to get out of the slump because again I feel like if it's been raining nine days in a row it's going to be raining the tenth day as well. And of course, that then contributes to my feeling of, I will never get out of this rut that I'm in. Yeah. And so it's a sort of double-edged trap there where you are blindsided when things go badly and when you experience stuckness, but also in the midst of that stuckness, you can't imagine it ever ending.
当我们预期不会有任何变化时，我们似乎被这一点蒙蔽了。但从被困住的角度来看，你现在可以看到一种情况，实际上你正在经历一段延长的低迷期，例如，很容易感觉到，你知道，我永远不会摆脱低迷，因为同样，我觉得如果连续九天下雨，第十天也会下雨。当然，这随后促成了我的感觉，我永远不会摆脱我所处的这种死胡同。是的。所以这是一个双刃陷阱，当事情进展糟糕时，你会被蒙蔽，当你体验到被困感时，但同样在那种被困感中，你无法想象它会结束。
You write about a video posted online by the actress, Brie Larson. when you experience stuckness, but also in the midst of that stuckness, you can't imagine it ever ending. You write about a video posted online by the actress, Bri Larson. She won an Academy Award for Best Actress for her role in the movie Room, and she's had leading roles in blockbuster movies like The Marvels. In this clip, she talks about the secret of her success.
你写了一段由女演员Brie Larson在线发布的视频。当你体验到被困感时，但同样在那种被困感中，你无法想象它会结束。你写了一段由女演员Bri Larson在线发布的视频。她凭借在电影《房间》中的角色获得了奥斯卡最佳女主角奖，并且她在像《惊奇队长》这样的好莱坞大片中担任主角。在这段片段中，她谈到了她成功的秘诀。
I got told no, 98 to 99% of the time. I know it's hard to fully wrap your brain around. It's even hard for me to wrap my brain around. I think of the fact that I've been on thousands and thousands and thousands and thousands of auditions. It's sort of crazy. So that's a lot of failure, Adam,
我被拒绝的次数占到98%到99%。我知道这很难完全理解。即使对我来说，也很难理解。我想到我参加过成千上万次试镜。这简直太疯狂了。所以，亚当，那意味着大量的失败。
and not what you think of when you think about a very successful movie star So often we focus on colossal success But for someone with with Brie Larson's degree of success to be transparent about her failures and the fact that by her own account It's 98 to 99% of the time that she's failing. I think is really disarming and and offers a real note of hope And so not surprisingly that people really latched onto that video and I found a very interesting piece of evidence. I'm wondering if there's an important insight here, which is that succeeding often means a sustained tolerance for failure. I mean,
这和你想到非常成功的电影明星时所想到的完全不同。我们经常关注巨大的成功，但对于像布丽·拉尔森（Brie Larson）这样成功的人来说，能够坦诚面对自己的失败，并且按照她自己的说法，她98%到99%的时间都在经历失败，我认为这真的让人放下戒备，并带来了一丝真正的希望。所以，人们对那个视频产生共鸣也就不足为奇了。我发现了一个非常有趣的证据。我想知道这里是否有一个重要的见解，那就是成功往往意味着对失败的持续容忍。我的意思是，
it sounds paradoxical, but you know, winners are not people who never lose. They're people who can tolerate losing long enough for things to break their way. Yeah, and there's a lot of research looking, for example, at the course of careers in various different pursuits. They look at artists, they look at film writers, they look at book writers and other people, and ask, where is the most successful period of that artist's life's work? And the answer is, it's hard to to predict and there are people they describe as having early in their careers, they have their biggest successes, some during the summer time in the middle of their careers, and then some during the fall or the winter time at the end of their careers.
这听起来很矛盾，但你知道，赢家并不是从不失败的人。他们是能够忍受失败，直到事情出现转机的人。是的，有很多研究，例如，观察各种不同职业生涯的进程。他们观察艺术家、电影编剧、书籍作家和其他人，并问，这位艺术家一生中最成功的时期是什么时候？答案是，这很难预测。有些人被描述为在职业生涯早期就取得了最大的成功，有些人是在职业生涯中期的夏季，还有一些是在职业生涯末期的秋季或冬季。
And so yet you don't know necessarily where those periods are going to arise, but you have to stay in the game, keep pushing even against maybe 98 to 99% of failure is loss and describes for the successes to emerge. Now, perhaps because our model of success is the model of, you know, I buy a lottery ticket and I hit the jackpot on the first try, that's the model. Many of us think we have to achieve success, you know, in one fell swoop. So we bet the house on some one thing and, you know, so we say this is going to be the golden ticket, but of course, if that one thing thing fails we've left ourselves nothing to fall back on
所以，你并不一定知道这些时期会在什么时候出现，但你必须留在游戏中，即使面对98%到99%的失败和损失，也要继续推进，直到成功出现。现在，也许因为我们的成功模式是，你知道，我买了一张彩票，第一次尝试就中了头奖，这就是那种模式。我们许多人认为我们必须一蹴而就地取得成功。所以我们把赌注押在某一件事情上，你知道，所以我们说这将是通往成功的金票，但当然，如果那件事失败了，我们就没有退路了。
Yeah, I think this sort of binary view of success and failure in our culture is really really damaging because Success really by that very narrow definition happens very very seldom And so there needs to be a stark reframing I think one of the best places to begin is to stop thinking about success as this kind of binary instant outcome. And to think of it more as a process or a journey or a system that you employ day after day. So instead of saying success is writing a hundred thousand words of a book, success needs to be something like waking up and writing 300 words today or sitting for an hour and writing and seeing what comes out of that because then at least you make it a narrower definition that means success happens much more often.
是的，我认为我们文化中这种对成功和失败的二元看法是非常非常有破坏性的，因为按照那个非常狭隘的定义，成功确实很少发生。因此，需要进行彻底的重构。我认为最好的开始方式之一是停止将成功视为一种二元的、即时的结果。而是将其更多地视为一个过程、一段旅程或一个你日复一日采用的系统。所以，不要说成功就是写出一本十万字的书，成功应该是像今天醒来写300个字，或者坐下来写一个小时，看看能写出什么，因为这样至少你缩小了定义，这意味着成功发生的频率会高得多。
And you also move the domain of success into something you can control rather than something that's outside of your control. Exactly. Yeah, you bring the locus of control inside which is really valuable, right? Because it's empowering, as opposed to forcing you to throw your hands up and say, I don't know what I can do about this. I'm at the mercy of all sorts of external constraints that I don't have much role over. And I think that's really, really hopeful and helps people move forward.
而且你也将成功的领域转移到了你可以控制的事情上，而不是你无法控制的事情上。完全正确。是的，你把控制点带到了内部，这非常有价值，对吧？因为它赋予了你力量，而不是强迫你举手投降说，我对此无能为力。我受制于各种我无法控制的外部约束。我认为这真的、真的很有希望，并能帮助人们前进。
You know, I remember talking some years ago with another Adam. This is Adam Grant at the University of Pennsylvania, and he told me there was a strong correlation between artists who are successful and artists who are prolific. You've looked at the same idea as well. Can you talk about how in some ways taking more shots on goal makes it more likely to also take really good shots on goal? Yeah, that's exactly right. That quality and quantity are really good chart angle? Yeah, that's exactly right. That quality and quantity are related strongly, that the more times you try, the more likely
你知道，我记得几年前和另一位亚当谈过。这是宾夕法尼亚大学的亚当·格兰特（Adam Grant），他告诉我，成功的艺术家和多产的艺术家之间有很强的相关性。你也研究过同样的想法。你能谈谈在某些方面，多尝试几次是否也更有可能实现真正好的目标吗？是的，完全正确。质量和数量是相关的，你尝试的次数越多，就越有可能
you are to hit on a success, and there are lots of reasons for that. One is that obviously by trying more, you learn what works and what doesn't, and so what you produce ultimately get stronger over time. But also, sometimes it's hard to know what will succeed, and so let's say there are ten different ways to do something. If you try three of them, you have a three-intention of hitting whatever the jackpot is. If you try all 10, one of them is going to succeed. And so you need to have those misses in order to ultimately have the success in aggregate.
获得成功，这有很多原因。一个原因是，显然通过尝试更多，你了解了什么有效，什么无效，所以你最终产生的结果会随着时间的推移而变得更强。但同时，有时很难知道什么会成功，所以假设有十种不同的方法来做某事。如果你尝试其中的三种，你就有十分之三的机会中头奖。如果你尝试所有10种，其中一种就会成功。所以你需要有那些失败，才能最终获得总体的成功。
And so that's a really important principle in any pursuit. It doesn't really matter what you're doing, but trying multiple approaches, experimenting, figuring out whether the dominant approach is the right one or whether you should try something a bit different is the way forward. We've looked at several ways that our own minds can become our worst enemies and cause us to become stuck. Of course, sometimes the problem is not inside our own minds,
所以这是任何追求中一个非常重要的原则。你做什么其实并不重要，但尝试多种方法、进行实验、弄清楚主导方法是否正确，或者你是否应该尝试一些不同的东西，才是前进的方向。我们已经研究了我们自己的思想如何成为我们最大的敌人并导致我们陷入困境的几种方式。当然，有时问题不在我们自己的思想内部，
we're just dealing with a problem that is really difficult. But it turns out, here too, there are things we can do and things we shouldn't do to get unstuck. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Adam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Adam Alter is a psychologist at NYU who studies how we get stuck and how to get unstuck. He has examined a number of mental traps we construct that can make it hard for us to extricate ourselves. But sometimes, the challenge is not inside our own minds. The problems we face are
我们只是在处理一个非常困难的问题。但事实证明，在这里，我们也可以做一些事情，也有一些事情我们不应该做，以摆脱困境。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain），我是香卡·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。亚当。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。亚当·奥尔特（Adam Alter）是纽约大学的一位心理学家，他研究我们如何陷入困境以及如何摆脱困境。他研究了我们构建的许多心理陷阱，这些陷阱可能使我们难以自拔。但有时，挑战并不在我们自己的思想内部。我们面临的问题是
inherently challenging. But here again, it turns out that our minds can play an important role in finding our way to breakthroughs. Adam, in the survey you conducted asking people about their experiences getting stuck, and one of your respondents talked about trying to learn to play the piano and another talked about trying to become a good artist. Can you tell me what they told you? Yeah, so they both explained that they had made some steady progress earlier on in the experience, but ultimately hit what they described as a plateau, that they couldn't improve
本质上具有挑战性的。但在这里，事实证明，我们的思想在找到突破口方面可以发挥重要作用。亚当，在你进行的调查中，询问人们关于他们陷入困境的经历，你的一位受访者谈到了尝试学习弹钢琴，另一位谈到了尝试成为一名优秀的艺术家。你能告诉我他们告诉了你什么吗？是的，他们都解释说，他们在经历的早期取得了一些稳定的进展，但最终遇到了他们所描述的平台期，他们无法再进一步提高。
further. They reached a particular point and then did not seem to continue to improve beyond that point. So here's the one about the piano. I've been trying to learn how to play the piano. I was making steady progress, but in the last couple of years,
他们达到了某一点，然后似乎没有继续超过那一点。所以这是关于钢琴的那一个。我一直在尝试学习如何弹钢琴。我取得了稳定的进展，但在过去几年里，
I feel I haven't improved at all. I continue to practice the basics, but I feel stuck and it's making me worry that I'll never improve. It feels as if I'm wasting my time. And then this one's from an artist. I've hit a plateau and can't seem to improve further. I need to practice to put my nose to the grindstone,
我觉得我根本没有进步。我继续练习基础知识，但我感到陷入了困境，这让我担心我永远不会进步。感觉就像我在浪费时间。然后这个来自一位艺术家。我遇到了一个平台期，似乎无法再进一步提高。我需要练习，要刻苦钻研，
to improve my skill in drawing portraits and landscapes. I need to learn how to be more creative and to find creative solutions to my problems. If you have an exercise program and have been doing it for a while, you have very likely encountered the plateau effect. Studies of athletes in nearly every sport show this too. Adam cites one study. This is research that looks at roughly 15,000 people over about seven years and looks at a very simple training regime that they took part in, and wanted to understand the effectiveness of this regime across time. And what the researchers found was that for the first year
以提高我画肖像和风景的技能。我需要学习如何更有创造力，并为我的问题找到创造性的解决方案。如果你有一个锻炼计划并且已经坚持了一段时间，你很可能遇到过平台效应。几乎每项运动的运动员研究也显示了这一点。亚当引用了一项研究。这是一项研究，观察了大约七年内约15,000人，并观察了他们参与的一种非常简单的训练方案，并希望了解该方案随时间的有效性。研究人员发现，在第一年
and sometimes two years in some of the respondents who are particularly responsive, people became fitter, they became healthier, they became happier in certain respects. But beyond that two-year process, there weren't great benefits to using exactly the same approach in the remaining three, four, five, six, seven years. And so by doing the same thing over and over and over again, responsiveness declines whether it's physical responsiveness
有时在一些反应特别灵敏的受访者中是两年，人们变得更健康，他们变得更强壮，在某些方面变得更快乐。但超过那个两年的过程，在剩下的三、四年、五年、六年、七年里，使用完全相同的方法并没有太大的好处。所以通过一遍又一遍地做同样的事情，反应能力会下降，无论是身体对训练方案的反应能力，
to a training regime or whether it's the approach you've been using to learn the piano or to draw a paint. And what explains this plateau effect, Adam? One for the bodies in particular is that you become habituated. And so your muscles perhaps adapt to what you're doing, and they stop responding in the same way as they did earlier on. They effectively become experts at coping with what you're throwing at them. And the problem with expertise with respect to muscles is they stop needing to try quite so hard
还是你用来学习钢琴或绘画的方法。是什么解释了这种平台效应，亚当？对于身体来说，特别是你变得习惯了。所以你的肌肉可能适应了你正在做的事情，它们停止以早期的相同方式做出反应。它们实际上成为了应对你扔给它们的东西的专家。而肌肉方面的专业知识的问题在于，它们不再需要那么努力地尝试
to do what it is you're asking of them. And so as a result, because you're not stretching them further, they don't continue to improve. And that's true of cardio fitness as well, and various other forms of fitness. So by changing things, you then reintroduce some stress into the situation, and that leads to greater improvement. And really, it's a similar idea with the piano or with art or with any other domain
去做你要求它们做的事情。因此，因为你没有进一步拉伸它们，它们就不会继续改善。心肺健康以及各种其他形式的健康也是如此。所以通过改变事物，你就会重新引入一些压力到这种情况中，这会导致更大的改善。真的，钢琴或艺术或任何其他领域也是类似的想法，
that you can do the same thing over and over again. And you might become more comfortable with it over time, but eventually that comfort just has no real value to you. You need to change things, and part of that is just making things a little bit more difficult, whether it's trying a new technique or stretching yourself in some other way without doing that, you're basically going to hit this point of stagnation. I want to talk about another kind of challenge we sometimes encounter. Sometimes the problems we're confronting are so complex that we find ourselves bewildered by the number of options before us.
你可以一遍又一遍地做同样的事情。随着时间的推移，你可能会对它感到更舒服，但最终那种舒适对你来说没有任何真正的价值。你需要改变事物，而这的一部分只是让事情变得稍微困难一点，无论是尝试一种新技术还是以其他方式拉伸自己，如果不这样做，你基本上会达到这个停滞点。我想谈谈我们有时遇到的另一种挑战。有时我们面临的问题太复杂了，以至于我们被面前众多的选择弄得不知所措。
And now throwing lots of spaghetti at the wall produces a mess rather than an insight. Can you talk about this idea that sometimes reducing our own options can be a worthwhile strategy? Yeah, I studied law as an undergraduate and one of the things they taught us very early on was you will always have too much information. You know, you'll get facts about a particular case. Most of them will be extraneous. They're not really relevant to the kernel of the case that's really important to understand. And your biggest job is to find what really matters, to simplify. And I think that's an incredibly valuable skill to use in any situation because so many things that we grapple with every day
现在，把很多意大利面扔到墙上只会产生混乱，而不是洞察力。你能谈谈这个想法吗，即有时减少我们自己的选择可能是一个值得的策略？是的，我本科学习法律，他们很早就教给我们的一件事是，你总是会有太多的信息。你知道，你会得到关于某个特定案件的事实。其中大部分将是无关紧要的。它们与理解案件核心的重要性并不真正相关。而你最大的工作是找到真正重要的事情，去简化。我认为这在任何情况下都是一种非常有价值的技能，因为我们每天处理的许多事情
are complex by nature. It really doesn't matter what kind of work you do. If you're a doctor, the process of diagnosis is going to be complicated. If you're a lawyer, it'll be complicated. In trying to understand the financial markets, there'll be too much information. And so I think the difference between being a great success
本质上都是复杂的。你从事什么样的工作真的不重要。如果你是一名医生，诊断的过程将会很复杂。如果你是一名律师，它会很复杂。在试图理解金融市场时，会有太多的信息。所以我认为成为巨大成功
and perhaps a more modest success is in learning how to instinctively figure out what really matters, stripping away what's what's not absolutely necessary and really imposing artificial constraints that make what might otherwise be overwhelmingly complex much simpler. French artist Pierre Solage, who has used a really unusual self-imposed restraint on himself in order to grant himself more freedom. What does he do? Yeah. So Solage talked about the fact that the business of art was very complex. You have just so many materials at your disposal. You have different media. And then, of course, once you narrow down the medium, you then still have to decide on color.
和也许更温和的成功之间的区别在于学习如何本能地弄清楚什么真正重要，剥离掉那些并非绝对必要的东西，并真正施加人为的约束，使原本可能极其复杂的事情变得简单得多。法国艺术家皮埃尔·苏拉热（Pierre Soulages），他对自己使用了非常不寻常的自我强加的限制，以便给自己更多的自由。他做了什么？是的。所以苏拉热谈到了艺术事业非常复杂的事实。你手头有太多的材料。你有不同的媒介。然后，当然，一旦你缩小了媒介范围，你仍然必须决定颜色。
And so what Salaj decided early, quite early on, was that he was just going to use black paint. And by stripping away the question of color of hue, he would leave himself with a much simpler set of decisions to make, and so he could really focus and refine his understanding of how to use that one tone of paint to create the work that he was making. And so he became known as the artist who only used black paint.
所以苏拉热很早就决定，他只会使用黑色颜料。通过剥离颜色和色调的问题，他会给自己留下一组更简单的决定，这样他就可以真正专注于并完善他对如何使用那种颜料来创作他正在创作的作品的理解。所以他被称为只使用黑色颜料的艺术家。
When you feel stuck because you have hit a dreaded plateau, the solution is to introduce change. Start a new kind of workout. If you are a writer of prose, try your handed poetry. If you're a musician, try playing your instrument with your non-dominant hand. Adam has also studied the idea that reframing problems as challenges can be effective in getting yourself unstuck. He has looked at one particular kind of problem that many people confront in workplaces and educational settings.
当你因为遇到了可怕的平台期而感到陷入困境时，解决方案是引入变化。开始一种新的锻炼方式。如果你是散文作家，尝试一下诗歌。如果你是音乐家，尝试用非惯用手演奏你的乐器。亚当还研究了将问题重构为挑战可以有效地让你摆脱困境的想法。他研究了许多人在工作场所和教育环境中面临的一种特定类型的问题。
There's a very well-known phenomenon in social psychology known as stereotype threat, which is the idea that if you know that you belong to a particular group that is negatively stereotyped makes it harder for you to perform well. So some of the research looked at women in mathematics, a domain that was at least historically in sexist norms seen as the domain of men. And so when women are reminded that they are women and they are trying to complete math tasks, there's some evidence that it becomes harder for them because they recognize that in addition to the baggage of having to overcome the challenges of the task, they also have to deal with the fact that they are part of a group that is negatively stereotyped in that domain. So that's this idea of stereotype threat, but a lot of what's experienced in a threat is subjective. It's the way you perceive the situation.
社会心理学中有一个非常著名的现象，称为刻板印象威胁，即如果你知道你属于一个被负面刻板印象的特定群体，这会使你更难表现良好。所以一些研究观察了数学领域的女性，这个领域至少在历史上在性别歧视规范中被视为男性的领域。因此，当女性被提醒她们是女性并且她们正在尝试完成数学任务时，有一些证据表明这变得更难了，因为她们认识到，除了必须克服任务挑战的负担之外，她们还必须处理她们是该领域中被负面刻板印象的群体的一部分这一事实。所以这就是刻板印象威胁的想法，但威胁中经历的很多东西是主观的。这是你感知情况的方式。
And so this research I did looked at trying to take people at Princeton who were like I was from an underrepresented background in the sense that we weren't from feeder schools that tended to send lots of students to Princeton and to ask them to complete a math task. And to have some of them think about that as a threatening situation, as a sort of test of their intellectual ability.
所以这项我做的研究试图让普林斯顿大学的人，那些像我一样来自代表性不足背景的人，在这个意义上，我们不是来自倾向于向普林斯顿输送大量学生的预备学校，并要求他们完成一项数学任务。并让其中一些人认为这是一种威胁性的情况，作为一种对他们智力能力的测试。
And for others to just recognize that this was just a challenge, it was something fun that they were doing, and to turn the dial down on that experience of threat and to show that even if you're from that underrepresented background in that context, you are still able to overcome that particular task if you see it as a challenge rather than as a threat. So it seems Adam that there are times when we know what we want, but we're stuck because we don't know how to get there, but at other times we're stuck because we simply don't know what we want. I want to play you a clip from a film that captures this feeling. In the 2003 movie Lost in Translation, Scarlett Johansson plays Charlotte, a young woman who
而对于其他人，只是认识到这只是一个挑战，这是他们正在做的有趣的事情，并调低那种威胁的体验，并表明即使你是在那种背景下来自代表性不足的背景，如果你将其视为挑战而不是威胁，你仍然能够克服那个特定的任务。所以亚当，似乎有时我们知道我们想要什么，但我们陷入困境是因为我们不知道如何到达那里，但在其他时候我们陷入困境是因为我们根本不知道我们想要什么。我想给你播放一段电影片段，捕捉这种感觉。在2003年的电影《迷失东京》（Lost in Translation）中，斯嘉丽·约翰逊（Scarlett Johansson）饰演夏洛特（Charlotte），一个年轻女子，她
feels adrift in her life, and she meets up with an over-the-haired movie star played by Bill Murray, and she asks him for guidance. I'm stuck. I just don't know what I'm supposed to be. I tried being a writer, but I hate what I write and I tried taking pictures, but there's some mediocre, you know, every girl goes through photography phase. So a motto that recurs in your book, Adam, is action above all. What does that mean? Yeah, it means that a lot of the book
在生活中感到漂泊，她遇到了比尔·默瑞（Bill Murray）饰演的一位过气的电影明星，她向他寻求指导。我陷入了困境。我只是不知道我应该成为什么样的人。我尝试过写作，但我讨厌我写的东西，我尝试过拍照，但有些平庸，你知道，每个女孩都会经历摄影阶段。所以，亚当，你书中反复出现的一个座右铭是“行动高于一切”。那是什么意思？是的，这意味着书中的很多内容
is about the emotional experience of being stuck and then about the mental strategies we can use to move forward. But all of that ultimately is in the service of action. Being stuck is about being physically in a particular place or mentally in a particular place and wanting to be somewhere else. The only way you can change that is not changing how you emotionally appraise the situation,
是关于陷入困境的情感体验，然后是我们可以用来前进的心理策略。但所有这些最终都是为了行动服务。陷入困境是关于身体上处于特定的地方或心理上处于特定的地方，并希望去别的地方。你改变这一点的唯一方法不是改变你如何从情感上评估这种情况，
not with mental strategies, but ultimately that thing you have to do more than anything else is to act, is to move in a particular direction. But why would action help us when we don't know where we want to go? By acting you reveal something to yourself. If I don't know, if I want to be a painter, if I want to be a writer, if I want to go. By acting you reveal something to yourself. If I don't know if I want to be a painter, if I want to be a writer, if I want to be a doctor, if I want to be a lawyer, I can sit here and ponder that question to a certain point there's value in that, but eventually thinking about it harder and more deeply just doesn't get me very far.
不是通过心理策略，但最终你必须做的最重要的事情是行动，是向特定的方向移动。但当我们不知道我们想去哪里时，行动为什么会帮助我们？通过行动，你向自己揭示了一些东西。如果我不知道，如果我想成为一名画家，如果我想成为一名作家，如果我想去。通过行动，你向自己揭示了一些东西。如果我不知道我是否想成为一名画家，如果我想成为一名作家，如果我想成为一名医生，如果我想成为一名律师，我可以坐在这里思考那个问题，在一定程度上是有价值的，但最终更努力、更深入地思考并不能让我走得太远。
What will get me somewhere is to inhabit the life of an artist or a painter or a doctor or a lawyer to take action to of an artist or a painter or a doctor or a lawyer to take action to do something that's a bit different. And even if I'm moving in the wrong direction, even if art turns out not to be my calling, the law is not my calling, and so on, I learn something about what either does work in the best case scenario or in the worst case scenario, I'm eliminating what doesn't. And that's tremendously valuable, certainly much more valuable than sitting still and just thinking, naval gazing, as it ultimately becomes.
能让我有所收获的是去体验艺术家、画家、医生或律师的生活，去采取行动去做一些稍微不同的事情。即使我朝着错误的方向前进，即使艺术最终不是我的使命，法律不是我的使命，等等，我也学到了一些关于什么在最好的情况下有效，或者在最坏的情况下，我正在消除什么无效。这非常有价值，当然比坐着不动、只是思考、最终变成“凝视肚脐”要更有价值得多。
You write about an interesting exercise involving the New York Times spelling bee, tell me what that puzzle involves and the hack to basically try and do better at it. You get a series of letters before you, and you have to make words out of those letters. And the letters, when you first open the app are in a particular configuration.
你写了一个关于涉及《纽约时报》拼字游戏（Spelling Bee）的有趣练习，告诉我那个谜题涉及什么，以及基本上尝试做得更好的技巧。你面前有一系列字母，你必须用这些字母组成单词。当你第一次打开应用程序时，字母处于特定的配置中。
There's a central letter, and then there are some letters, six letters surrounding that central letter. But there's a button that allows you to shuffle the order of those letters to randomly reallocate them. And what's really fascinating is I didn't intuit this when I first started doing the puzzle, but what I'll do today is I'll sit with the letters
有一个中心字母，然后有一些字母，六个字母围绕着那个中心字母。但有一个按钮允许你打乱这些字母的顺序，随机重新分配它们。真正令人着迷的是，我刚开始做这个谜题时并没有直觉到这一点，但我今天会做的是，我会坐在字母前
as they arrive when I open the app. And I'll try to find words for say 10 minutes and I'll get to a certain level. And usually it's not as far as I want to go. I want to, there's different levels of achievement. I always try to go for the top level. And if I fall a little bit short of that, I'll hit the shuffle button.
当它们到达时，当我打开应用程序时。我会尝试找到单词，比如10分钟，我会达到一定的水平。通常它没有我想达到的那么远。我想，有不同水平的成就。我总是尝试达到最高水平。如果我离那个水平还差一点，我会按下打乱按钮。
It'll reorient the letters. It'll change the order of them. And what's fascinating is I've been staring at these letters. It shouldn't matter where they are, but by moving them into a new position, suddenly a whole raft of new words appear and are available to me. And it's, if it can work in this very impoverished context,
它会重新定位字母。它会改变它们的顺序。真正令人着迷的是，我一直盯着这些字母。它们在哪里其实不重要，但通过将它们移动到一个新的位置，突然间一大批新单词出现了，并且对我可用。而且，如果它能在这种非常贫乏的环境中工作，
where all you're looking at is exactly the same set of seven letters, just in slightly different places. If it works there and un-sticks you there, if you can adopt a pretty serious, profound change of perspective in other areas of life, the payback is pretty dramatic. There's a great return on that investment. I want to talk about a challenge that you confronted in your own life, and I think this might
你所看到的只是完全相同的一组七个字母，只是在稍微不同的地方。如果它在那里工作并让你摆脱困境，如果你能在生活的其他领域采取一种非常严肃、深刻的视角改变，回报是相当巨大的。那项投资有很好的回报。我想谈谈你在自己生活中遇到的一个挑战，我认为这可能
be a useful example of a problem that might be basically unsolvable. You were in your late 20s and you felt torn between remaining in the United States where you had great academic and career opportunities and returning home to Australia and to your family. Describe those two forces, Adam, and what it felt like to be pulled in different directions. Yeah, this is an interesting moment. I'd been in the United States for five years in grad school. And if all went well, I would have a PhD in,
是一个有用的例子，说明一个基本上无法解决的问题。你在20多岁末期，感到在留在美国（你有很好的学术和职业机会）和回到澳大利亚回到你的家人身边之间感到撕裂。描述那两种力量，亚当，以及被拉向不同方向的感觉是什么样的。是的，这是一个有趣的时刻。我在美国读研究生五年了。如果一切顺利，我将获得博士学位，
then I would do something next. I wasn't sure exactly what that next would be. One option was to return back to Australia, to return to the country that I'd come from before. I'm very close to my family, and I felt that it was difficult to be away from them for five years. Another option was to keep moving forward in my career in the United States. And so I did that.
然后我会做接下来的事情。我不确定接下来会是什么。一个选择是回到澳大利亚，回到我之前来的国家。我和我的家人非常亲近，我觉得离开他们五年很困难。另一个选择是继续在美国推进我的职业生涯。所以我那样做了。
But the experience of moving from grad school into the role of an assistant professor at NYU, I found it overwhelming all over again. I felt a little bit stuck. I wasn't sure exactly what direction to pull my resources. I felt a little bit unmoored. And at the time, I was 29 and thinking a lot about what it was like to be at the end of my 20s and moving into my 30s. a lot about what it was like to be at the end of my 20s and moving into my 30s. And I decided that I needed some big goal to act as a kind of orienting point.
但从研究生院转到纽约大学助理教授角色的经历，我发现它再次让我不知所措。我感到有点陷入困境。我不确定到底该把资源引向哪个方向。我感到有点漂泊。当时我29岁，想了很多关于20多岁末期和进入30多岁是什么感觉。我决定我需要一个大目标来作为一个定位点。
And so I decided that I was gonna run a marathon and to spend four months training with a team and to run the New York City marathon. And there was something profoundly unsticking about that activity of taking on that new goal that gave me somewhere to pour my anxieties. And it really felt like a great unsticking about that activity of taking on that new goal, that it gave me somewhere to pull my anxieties and it really felt like a great unsticking moment and I think liberated me to move forward in my life that I just started in New York City. Why do you think running a marathon helps sort of figure out where you should live your
所以我决定我要跑一场马拉松，花四个月的时间和一个团队一起训练，并参加纽约市马拉松。那种承担新目标的活动中有一种深刻的摆脱困境的东西，它给了我一个倾倒焦虑的地方。它真的感觉像是一个伟大的摆脱困境的活动，承担那个新目标，它给了我一个倾倒焦虑的地方，它真的感觉像是一个伟大的摆脱困境的时刻，我认为它解放了我，让我能够继续我刚在纽约市开始的生活。你为什么认为跑马拉松有助于弄清楚你应该在哪里生活你的
life? I mean, the two things seem completely unrelated to each other. Yeah, they do. So one of the things that happens, this is why I mentioned that I was in my late 20s just imagining being 30, is that that's one of the moments in life. I have some research on this with a colleague of mine, Hal Hirschfield, showing that when our ages end in a nine, 29, 39, 49 and so on, it's a moment when we zoom back and think about the meaningfulness of our lives. We think about whether we're making the right life decisions. We sort of see the passage of time much more vividly than we do at age, say, 24, 25,
生活？我的意思是，这两件事看起来完全无关。是的，它们确实无关。所以发生的事情之一是，这就是为什么我提到我20多岁末期只是想象30岁，这是人生中的时刻之一。我和我的同事哈尔·赫什菲尔德（Hal Hirschfield）对此有一些研究，表明当我们的年龄以9结尾时，29、39、49等等，这是一个我们回顾并思考我们生活意义的时刻。我们思考我们是否做出了正确的人生决定。我们看到的时光流逝比我们在24、25岁时要生动得多，
34, 35 in the middle of those decades. And at that moment, just having a goal imbued my life with meaning and sort of made me feel that I could move forward again, even if it was an unrelated goal, the mere fact of having that goal gave me that sense of momentum that I felt was important at that time in my life. I mean, I think what I'm partly hearing is that when we are feeling stark, feeling like we have movement in some domain of our lives,
34、35岁，在那些十年的中间。而在那一刻，仅仅有一个目标就赋予了我的生活意义，并让我觉得我可以再次前进，即使它是一个不相关的目标，仅仅拥有那个目标的事实就给了我那种我在人生那个阶段认为很重要的动力感。我的意思是，我想我部分听到的是，当我们感到陷入困境时，感觉我们在生活的某个领域有进展，
even if it isn't the primary domain in which we are feeling stark, can be helpful in unsticking us. Exactly. Yeah, I think the sense of movement, the sense of velocity is more important than what the velocity specifically and narrowly, concretely represents. It's just the feeling that you are not stagnant. Adam Alter is a psychologist at NYU. He's the author of the book, An Atomy of a Breakthrough.
即使它不是我们感到陷入困境的主要领域，也可以帮助我们摆脱困境。完全正确。是的，我认为运动感、速度感比速度具体、狭隘、具体代表什么更重要。这只是你没有停滞的感觉。亚当·奥尔特是纽约大学的一位心理学家。他是《突破的解剖》（Anatomy of a Breakthrough）一书的作者。
How to get unstuck when it matters most. Adam, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me, Shankar. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. Next week in our YouTube.io series, how to build habits that work for who you are now and who you'll be in the future. If we start to think about how we relate to our future selves,
如何在最重要的时候摆脱困境。亚当，谢谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你的邀请，香卡。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。下周在我们的YouTube.io系列中，如何建立适合你现在和未来身份的习惯。如果我们开始思考我们如何与未来的自己建立联系，
then it can start to shed some light while we sometimes act in these ways that may seem shortsighted. If you love the ideas we explore on the show and would like to support our work, please consider joining our new podcast subscription Hidden Brain Plus. You'll find conversations you won't hear anywhere else. Plus, we'll bring you a feature called Your Questions Answered, where some of our most popular guests respond to listeners follow-ups about their work. You can find these and other episodes for
那么它就可以开始阐明为什么我们有时会以这些看起来目光短浅的方式行事。如果你喜欢我们在节目中探讨的想法，并希望支持我们的工作，请考虑加入我们的新播客订阅《隐藏的大脑Plus》（Hidden Brain Plus）。你会发现你在其他任何地方都听不到的对话。此外，我们将为你带来一个名为“回答你的问题”（Your Questions Answered）的功能，我们最受欢迎的一些嘉宾会回应听众关于他们工作的后续问题。你可以在
subscribers by going to the Apple Podcasts app and searching for Hidden Brain. Or you can find these and other episodes for subscribers by going to the Apple Podcast app and searching for Hidden Brain. Or you can find us at apple.co slash Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
订阅者通过前往Apple Podcasts应用程序并搜索《隐藏的大脑》找到这些和其他剧集。或者你可以通过前往Apple Podcast应用程序并搜索《隐藏的大脑》找到这些和其他剧集。或者你可以在apple.co/HiddenBrain找到我们。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。很快再见。你 这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。